this West London house has been turned
from a two and a half bedroom family
home into six small bed sets it's one of
many developments in this area meeting
the demand for social tenants to be put
up by private landlords local resident
John Knowles is concerned in my view
it's very short-term because we're not
really seeing a solution to homelessness
here we're not really certainly not
seeing a solution to the housing problem
these guys are inflating rents he says
that ultimately everyone loses from
social tenants being placed in homes
like these these are not appropriate
places for them to be housed because
they're far too small they violate
national space standards they violate
London's space standards they have no
shared amenity there is no sense of
community regenerating in these places
just coming inside this small
two-and-a-half bedroom house it's a
familiar story has been converted into
six separate beds it's these narrow
corridors really the only communal space
except a small kitchen each of these
locked room with a small shower and
bathroom inside a really tiny living
space for these men who are being housed
by homelessness charities by local
authorities and crucially for each of
these small units a private landlord is
making nine hundred and eighty three
pounds a month in rent most of which is
coming from the taxpayer housing benefit
payments to private landlords have
doubled in a decade from 4.6 billion
pounds in 2006 to nine point three
billion pounds last year it's more
expensive to how social tenants and
private properties costing the taxpayer
a thousand pounds per family more over
the course of the year than if they were
housed in the social rented sector the
profits are driving more and more
private companies to convert family
houses into socially funded bed sets
like the one next door to this local
resident and her family and you think
it's been converted into six bedrooms at
least six yes no I can see I know it's
there were kitchen units come in so III
assume it's now six bedrooms plus one
kitchen unit it looks more less the same
size as your house what you know of the
size this house what do you think those
six units will be like like prison cells
that's smaller
landlord say that the higher costs of
properties like these are justified
unlike social housing associations
private sector landlords have to charge
the kind of price that covers their cost
but also that makes a profit and they
never really means the private renting
is going to be more expensive than
social renting Sky News attempted to
contact the landlord in question for
these properties but did not receive a
response the government says it is
bringing the Housing Benefit bill under
control and that the amount going to
private landlords has been falling since
2012 but billions continue to flow into
private landlords pockets some would say
that means taxpayers paying more and
getting less F wash Sky News